what's our take on russia and ukraine
does this have any impact on fed policy
decisions or the financial system or any
of this stuff or is this like more of a
geopolitical thing and not really
finance related well uh i'll start by
saying if if this gets goes awry it'll
be impacting everything it'll be
impacting how you and i live our lives
but the reality is most geopolitical
conflicts or exogenous events and
markets tend to price those end very
quickly and move on
what markets care about are trending
rates of growth and trending rates of
inflation and trending direction and
monetary and fiscal policy um and so to
the extent that the this russian
skirmish has any impact on that that's
what will impact markets but it's my
view that it won't um it's also my view
that this is just a big game for putin
to get the west to the table to get them
to back off their uh sort of eastern
expansion with respect to nato i think
that's pretty clear i i feel like putin
is just sitting there he like he's fools
like he's like he thinks he's playing
like uh was it a risk right or whatever
he's like i'm gonna move these people up
close to the border i'm gonna move them
back nope they were never there like and
i'm sure there's a whole bunch of
nonsense that we don't even know about
right so it's like hard to underwrite
like how serious is it how much is it
propaganda or whatever like it just
feels like a game you know what he's
doing he's
we've all been there like you have an
ex-girlfriend i haven't put my military
troops on the border yet
no no i'm bringing it back to layman's
terms so
how putin is behaving right now is that
like ex-girlfriend who's constantly
talking about her new boyfriend on
instagram and constantly taking photos
and pictures of him just to like make
you jealous just like kim kardashian
basically
putin is behaving like kim kardashian
right now and uh ultimately likely to be
proven effective because right now
neither the u.s nor germany really the
the broader west can afford to have a
military skirmish uh develop and and
obviously out of this because we're
already dealing with you know sort of a
pretty rapid expansion in crude oil
prices and if we take it wti be above 90
a barrel to 100 110 120 a barrel you're
that's a recession automatically in the
us economy yeah it feels like uh
we're only scratching the surface of the
game they could play yeah like this
whole like oh we may invade ukraine we
may not what was what were they doing a
couple years ago there was like uh was
it ukraine or was there
another small jurisdiction where like i
remember there's like a cnn reporter and
he was like in the snow and they were
like oh we're like fortifying the
position or something whatever was going
on and i remember being like oh damn
that might be real and then like if you
actually think about uh over the last
five years trump was in office we almost
went to war with iran world war three
was popping on twitter
and then he was tweeting little rocket
man at north korea right like it feels
like this game gets played a lot but for
some reason i think that the uh
americans look at this and like yo
putin is a different
thing here like you know what's going on
did you ever read a red notice the book
uh uh bill browder no i'm not talking
about it
you gotta read it uh
it it's not necessarily like a uh
educational book like in your about
trading or investing or anything like
that uh it's more so um it's a true
story and bill browder was an american
who uh in the 80s i believe went to
russia and uh he um
found that a lot of the companies were
not exactly reporting accurate numbers
and so it looked like they were much
smaller than they actually were
and it's unclear at least from my
reading of it was it for taxation
purposes was it to prevent the
government from coming in and
confiscating their assets or whatever
but he basically started to buy up stock
in the companies and they'd be like yo
they actually did 20 times more revenue
than they said they did right
and the stock prices would explode and
who made a killing yeah so kind of like
activist investor-esque
but he was just doing it in you know uh
russia it's actually interesting that
the opposite i read there's a book
called uh red capitalism about china's
financial sector and it's a it's
basically the opposite of that which is
you know they've grossly exaggerated um
their size and might and and and
sophistication of the financial this is
going back you know 10 years ago i think
the book came out in 809 obviously
they've taken significant leaps forward
um in developing you know their
capability since then but it was sort of
a kind of casting of casting a bit of a
doubt on what had become the only growth
story in town you know really throughout
the early 2000s and into the early part
of the 2010s yeah so what happens with
him which is uh uh i don't know why some
people downplay some people overplay
there's probably a lot of nuance in
there is that he uh he ends up becoming
wealthier and wealthier and wealthier
and wealthier and at one point he's
talking about everyone from putin to
other investors et cetera and he's just
talking about him like you know it's
like hey you got a hedge fund i got a
hedge fund right like whatever yeah but
then there's like the consolidation of
power all this stuff and so long story
short is uh he literally gets to the
point where he's scared for his safety
and uh he leaves the country and at some
point uh according to his you know kind
of telling of it um the government the
police whatever go to his lawyer's
office lawyers russian and they
basically confiscate documents and you
know illegally right in terms of uh they
just walk in and they basically beat him
up and take it and they arrest him
they end up killing his lawyer uh in the
book sorry to ruin it for who those
haven't read uh but his lawyer's name
was uh sergey um uh miniskov i think is
how you say it i may have it uh or
minitsky i think is actually i say it um
and so people in the united states may
have heard of uh the economic sanctions
the minitski act
and that's all because bill browder went
to u.s politicians and was like hey pay
attention to this and did all this work
got john mccain a bunch of these
politicians actually go ahead and live
with these sanctions but what's crazy
about the whole story is he now still to
this day he writes in the book like he
goes into a restaurant he goes in the
kitchen and watches them make his food
wow because he's so scared that whatever
and so red notice is like uh kind of
like america's top ten most wanted but
uh the interpol has a red nose which is
like you're an international fugitive
and so at some point russia convinced uh
interpol to release a red notice on him
and then he's able to basically say well
hold on a second here like that's in
fast and the furious too is it
oh my god i think that's a true story
yeah
it's not to not to shift gears but like
to me what you just described is is one
of the reasons i i you know personally
tend to be very
anti you know
corporate tax evasion
and you know because you know it's one
thing to run a business and obviously
we're all trying to turn profits as
business owners
but part of you know
operating in this wonderful country that
we live in is understanding that there's
a rule of law and this you know you
don't have to worry about the government
you know beating you up and murdering
you and taking documents and things of
that nature you don't have to worry
about thugs you know doing the same
thing
and so ultimately you know we're paying
for that we're paying for that with our
military we're paying for that you know
with our judicial system we're paying
for that with everything and so
ultimately you know to me i think when
companies try to take their tax burdens
to zero yet they want to sell goods and
services to american consumers on
american soil to me i think that's very
unpatriotic yeah the the other piece of
this whole thing it feels like uh is
there an argument that we ended the war
in afghanistan and like this is hey how
do we create more economic uh growth is
like
where can we go to war next like how
much do you put a weight into the like
war generates economic activity economic
growth and therefore we're a country
that given you know debt to gdp and kind
of all the the challenges that we have
that we have to constantly be going to
war with somebody
yeah so i would look at it from
different lines i i generally agree with
your sentiment in the sense that
there is a
underlying motive to constantly be
engaged in military conflict now this
kind of military conflict kinetic
conflict tends to be less valuable
certainly at this particular point in
the in the time space continuum right
now our military conflict is and uh dr
pippa maldgren is kind of the world
authority on a lot of this so i'm just
parroting some of the things she said in
recent publications but you know we're
having this big cyber warfare that's
kind of going unnoticed um you know
mainstream media and that's where a lot
of the sort of development and spending
uh the governments are doing um with
respect to military uh spending uh
that's a lot that's where that's going
so i it strikes me that the risk reward
for getting into a kinetic skirmish um
if you think about crude oil going from
90 a barrel to 120 plus dollars a barrel
to me that's a poor trade a better trade
would just be to dump money into the cia
and uh ride around in submarines so oil
what is it 40 bucks u.s uh producers
become uh
become unprofitable i think somewhere in
that range yeah so i mean that number is
mark now remember change is uh
fluctuates with the price of energy
prices and so you know the last
estimates are somewhere between 50 60 a
barrel now as long as we stay above that
at the current yeah they're making tons
of money they just don't want to drill
yep and so when it goes to 100 120 this
is the whole argument of like uh what
was a couple months ago the us was
talking about we have to tap into our
strategic reserves because russia saudi
arabia a number of other countries
around the world were slowing down the
pace at which they were uh uh producing
oil and that seemed to be also a
geopolitical game that was going on
exactly yeah no tapping into the
strategic petroleum reserves is the
equivalent of peeing in the ocean
we've all been there i mean you know
it's you're not making a dent
yeah it's just it just feels like uh
sometimes our solutions like it said
you're just like look by the way i'm not
an expert right so like i don't know
sure like
it sounds strategic yeah
right yeah um all right so and then what
about uh the situation going on in uh
canada like we've been talking a bunch
about this what what are your thoughts
so you need to fill me on that i tend
not to uh concern myself with non-market
moving events until they move the market
um so so i think
this is my view on it the reason why
we're so interested in it is uh
years and years ago one of the first
really big inflection points for bitcoin
was uh wikileaks
had came under an absolute [ __ ] storm
and a lot of financial organizations
started to shut down their bank accounts
freeze payments kind of all the
financial censorship stuff that we now
know that they they can do and will do
yeah and uh when they did that wikileaks
said hey we'll accept bitcoin yeah and
uh i believe it's satoshi let me make
sure i don't want to uh misquote here um
but the uh the quote that satoshi had
um was yeah so uh satoshi at some point
um
said wikileaks has kicked the hornet's
nest and the swarm is headed towards us
and i believe
that was one of the last things that
satoshi said
and it
from the analysis that people have kind
of looked at is
it was not just wikileaks it was just
like bitcoin's becoming too popular too
quickly it's not necessarily built for
this we're gonna attract a lot of law
enforcement totally nation state you
know intelligence etc uh
this may not be what we want to do yeah
um now obviously we've got to the point
that we've gotten to but that was the
first like mainstream
hey what is bitcoin why is this
important what is his wikileaks thing
whatever
i feel like there's been many between
now and uh between then and now but this
is another
massive one where people are like wait a
second
whether you agree with the protesters or
not you're telling me that the banks can
freeze the payments you're telling me
that the banks can confiscate the uh
crowdfunding uh platforms can literally
confiscate the money like what is going
on so so fill me in what's the what's
the 22nd like headline so long story
short is uh there's a couple of truckers
that became a lot of truckers that
became literally now the uh uh a 70
kilometer long convoy and they're
blocking the major road where most of
the
drove across canada to ottawa yeah they
filled the streets of ottawa with trucks
and they're not moving so they basically
gridlock the city
and then there is a specific uh i think
it's a bridge uh and kind of highway
that is a major trade route between
canada and the united states and
basically uh if not blocking making it
very difficult to get uh transportation
and goods across
and so of course there's two different
perspectives right the most extreme
versions are uh these are people who are
protesting vaccine and mass mandates
they they don't believe that their
government should actually come after
them 90 of truckers in canada reportedly
are vaccinated so it's not a we don't
want to be vaccinated it's just you
shouldn't tell us and our fellow
citizens
uh and so we're gonna do something about
it we're gonna basically make you
uncomfortable and we're gonna you know
go and protest the government argument
is these people are uh terrorists
and uh the canadian government has
literally come out and said uh if you
are participating if your uh vehicle is
used in the protest we are going to uh
cancel your insurance on your vehicle we
are going to impound the vehicles uh if
you try to send more than 25 to these
people we will freeze your account we
will uh confiscate your fault like what
bad nasty nasty [ __ ] is bad
he's taking hell on this one
there's no chance he's gonna go away so
of course what are they like if people
go back in you know social media history
and he said all the right things years
before things like you know hey we
shouldn't try to crush dissent uh you
know any government tries to crush
dissent it loses its morals i stand with
hong kong's right to protest
[Music]
people believe canada was a liberal
democracy yeah and now all of a sudden
he is just acting crazy and so literally
it's gotten to the point where i saw a
clip yesterday from uh i i think it's
called parliament uh
canadians will correct me immediately if
i got that wrong um but the the
parliament is kind of wild in canada
where like the two political parties are
on either side and somebody stands up
says something and there's kind of like
uh i don't know what the guy is but he's
like the presider like kind of like the
judge yeah and so he's like okay your
time's up okay you know uh uh respected
you know uh prime minister go ahead what
do you have to say and yesterday uh some
woman just took him to town like she she
was just going after him and uh you know
her whole side was i was clapping and
everything and he stood up and goes
while the conservatives would like to
stand with people with swastikas right
and they all started screaming at him
like it's like a free fro it's like
crazy this is
borderline comedy if it wasn't so
serious